I'm not gonna go high like these guys
who don't trust their own skill sets I'm
gonna go low and work in closer from
there what what are you trying to do so
I've been heating to upgrade my phone
for a while Nikko mentioned that we're
gonna do an archery livestream my phone
kind of got volunteered
I don't exactly like the idea of my
phone getting shot with an arrow
especially because I have to go to San
Francisco with Sam tonight Niko assured
me he was like oh no it's not gonna get
shot because we're gonna try to shoot
next to the phone that's the goal
hopefully I get shot right the
livestream starts in 14 minutes
so I'm trying to evacuate the Titanic
here and I'm trying to like get all my
voice recordings and stuff I don't lose
10 minutes
try not to phone hit the palm you buy
everybody a burrito or you give
everybody a Stephen Spock for the love
of God horizontal horizontal horizontal
you want horizontal you got to go over
here YouTube you know what intern who
played our tree with us
nothing do not shoot the phone the phone
will be on the target it's not funny to
shoot the phone it's not goofy to shoot
the phone don't shoot the phone we don't
go get those briefs you get those buried
yes and bring them to us I'm like
Stevens box where so I was just one
arrow at a time we take turns after that
one arrow we're gonna start elevating
the stakes maybe two arrows three arrows
four arrows and we start doing multiple
arrows your first one you'll want to be
about as far away as possible in each
arrow has to be consecutively closer
you're shooting a real bow and arrow
safety first take your time a quick note
on drawing the bow I'm seeing a lot of
this and then letting go that's not good
technique that's not good form take your
time put your finger up guide the arrow
all the way back all draw that means the
arrow tip is close to your finger here
lower your finger and then release just
a nice easy let go just to show you here
that this isn't training arrows here
we're not gonna puncture a hole straight
through the screen is that thicker than
a phone slightly thicker come on there
we go if I can't puncture the screen
with one strike I don't belong in this
competition run right through it blew
the back off that arrow will destroy the
phone and probably go straight through
it let's all pray for Nick's phone hey
Lynn hey everybody welcome to the Sam
and Nico channel youtube.com slash Sam
and Nico
no I'm not ready can't just say ready
and do it are you ready I think I'm
ready hey we have a really cool
announcement regarding our corridor
store with our merchandising stay tuned
to the end of this video to find out
what I'm talking about wait no now I
just got done doing my fourth ever 48
hour film festival you have 48 hours two
days to make a movie from start to
finish after every 48 hour film festival
you walk away and you're like I'm never
doing that again if you're a filmmaker
and you want to sharpen your skills or
just test yourself go do this
it's like injecting filmmaking interior
your jugular storytelling go out and
sign up get a group of friends together
one person to edit one person to shoot
go make something you have to register
as a team you don't want to do this by
yourself at least five people on crew so
you need to really delegate the jobs you
get these people together ahead of time
actors ahead of time you can get
costumes ahead of time even locations
the thing is though they give you a
randomly selected prompt that genre
character usually usually there's a
lines that you need to include in your
script get out of town or something like
that so we get first shot off by like
12:30 way behind schedule we wanted to
get our first off by 9:00 we're already
behind schedule that affects morale for
the crew I didn't even have time to do a
shot list you don't have time because
the director hands me the script and I'm
like all right well first scene let's go
here's where the challenge comes in cuz
the cinematographer I just have to go
off the top of my head with shots start
with your why'd you go in for coverage
you got any inserts you need and that's
the format you have to follow because
that's the most bare-bones way to shoot
something started around 12 you didn't
finish until 10:30 and no one sleeps no
one sleeps everyone's been on set what
26 hours but it's 10:30 and the final
cuts do at 5:00 so you got seven hours
so you have to edit the whole thing it
turned out to be a very rough edit you
got the footage and they had to just put
something together
I've definitely figured out some things
that will help you to maximize your
efficiency and keep your crew sane while
doing any sort of timed filmmaking
competition on any film set you're gonna
reach that point where you're all
questioning why
in bed you know like we've all dealt
with that I'm sure Carmichael you have
at the same time like this is meant to
be a fun thing where you're not meant to
question everything about the universe
and life itself the point the point
should be to get as close as possible
[Applause]
closer than everyone else
every tremble is a real light tremble I
didn't get closer though but at least I
didn't hit it he can someone tell me if
I'm aiming at the right spot I'm just
out it's cool I got a flight to catch I
had a perfect shot lined up I'm closer
I put a nice another hole in our door to
hell round three there's something
really cool about shooting and having it
stick there I'd never do it on purpose
but it feels pretty
it feels pretty badass go again for
three each one has to consecutively be
closer yes first let me try to put in
like the corner closest of the oh that's
pretty close I got pretty close I need
to target it's in the target I don't
think sometimes you smell that smells
like steaks I'm not gonna go high like
these guys who don't trust their own
skill sets I'm gonna go low and work in
closer from there
what what are you trying to do your life
man greatest moment of your life better
than you being married Wow technically
closer guys so this is not barrel why is
it still here
sigh because Nick embedded it into the
metal door alright closer than that
arrow four arrows in from the outside of
a giant target with a tiny phone that's
not real estates real stakes is it as
close as you can't without hitting it
closest person wins the hambone jar or
free burritos from everybody for life
it's really refreshing because you don't
have time to procrastinate and that's
like really free so the first thing
probably the most broad thing because it
affects everything else it starts with
the writing for the love of God
start with a simple compact yet
hard-hitting idea a couple locations at
most couple characters and give yourself
the time to do it well you want to aim
for like around six pages that's
probably doable on 12 hours simple idea
great execution if you go over you know
four takes then slow down there Scorsese
you're always gonna be on the clock it's
always gonna feel stressful no matter
what even if you have this simple idea
should you have VFX probably don't have
time if you want to go for it it
requires having your VFX artists on
standby waiting for the footage to come
in don't underestimate the power of your
post-production in this process because
even if things go janky onset you
usually can tweak them in some way in
post if you don't have time and post
you're stuck with that jank and Dobby
winds get them out of there try to only
shoot for twelve hours after that your
crew is gonna start getting really
grumpy but if you can get your editor
all the footage by 12:00 midnight that
is the ideal thing because that means
that the editor has all night and all of
Sunday up until the drop off to give
that edit some love I think a much more
efficient way than
one writer do all the writing ahead of
time and then hand it off to the crew is
to get everyone in on the writing
process get a writers room there's
something to be said about people who
are on the production collaborating on
the idea for the script when you get to
set there's more familiarity with the
material people feel a little bit more
inspired by the project rather than the
handed something make this a reality it
gives everyone from different
departments their chance to weigh in on
logistical issues in the script as well
before you start shooting my job is to
light and to shoot if I had been in on
the writing process I could have weighed
in with some ideas that would helped us
minimize covered minimize the locations
that we had a shoot in that would have
sped the process along lastly don't take
everything so seriously when you're
doing this you got a freaking day to
make a movie it's meant to test you it's
meant to push you to your limits there's
gonna be a point where everyone's grumpy
you feel like just so beaten down and
tired maybe at the scene isn't going
away maybe you're behind schedule you
probably will be everyone else on that
crew is feeling the same way don't
assume that anyone's out to get you
leave your ego at the door if you're an
actor and you have to pick up a light
stand move it do it if your
cinematographer and you have to hold a
boom on the side of camera while you can
operate it do it simple idea great
execution time for post-production also
you get to like go to a screening and
stuff and see your film up on the screen
and also possibly win it's a competition
of your film wins the city you represent
that city and you move on to compete
against other people's films that have
competed in the same festival in other
cities I'm gonna try to get corridor to
do a 48 hour film festival I talked to
Sam already he was down I think we could
do well hey you guys want to hear what
the enough oh we're bringing back a
whole bunch of shirts and hats that were
limited edition runs only so now we're
bringing them back for Black Friday on a
sale you guys can finally get them if
you miss it the first time around we'll
have more details next week about which
shirts and hats will be available until
then start saving your money because
it's gonna be great Dovie we have put
two arrows in us
eight inches here technically closer all
right what you guys wanted you're gonna
feel what it's like to write here this
is actually a walk in I don't think it's
close enough I'm going for it dude I
have yet to do some really close shots
you're gonna go right to the phone am i
oh that's probably amber learning that's
gonna mess up the feed and exit out the
alert here we go Nick lower I love
watching the feed seeing the arrows slam
into the target by the phone
closer
I did get closer hasn't gone yet
by the way rim
names Billy Little Billy yeah right aim
technique freaks me out he's like oh wow
it's about like four inches between the
lens so two-and-a-half inches from the
phone itself you think you pull that out
of a metal door what this is where we go
the danger on all my life I've waited to
play the gentleman's game and now it's
here real stakes real challenges whoever
gets closest to the phone without
hitting it wins a memo for this here we
go
you wanted to show you get to them
[Music]
this is the end result still on but the
screen is dead thanks for tuning in that
was great
kind of wanted to show you guys a really
cool close shot flew too close to the
Sun it's good to close to the Sun man
but you know what you're not gonna honor
it now I know what it feels like with an
arrow man that was your phone yeah go to
stop watching this video look up 48
hours film festivals I want to see you
out there if you're in Los Angeles you
better be competing against us next year
[Music]